hi I want to meet you in reality you'll  never meet this person this Photograph  isn't real it was generated by a neural  network romance scammers often use fake  photos to create accounts unfortunately  such a cruel means of deception is very  profitable so how can you spot a scammer  who dreams of stealing not your heart  but your money they always have a reason  why they can't meet up or chat via video  call sorry I'm late what happened  nothing I just really didn't want to  come  your romantic relationship is developing  too fast  and they also ask you for money it could  be money for them to come and see you  pay their debts or pay for some medical  treatment the reason could be anything  if someone does manage to deceive you  contact the police but so that this  doesn't happen to you subscribe and we  will tell you how to not get lost in the  online jungle